our greatest pilot was like what the
and they're seeing it on the radar
which I've never seen yeah
we pull up a picture
because when I was growing up was oh
that's a weather balloon it's a
refraction of the light I love that that
would work though someone would say this
high speed moving object that's moving
in a way that's beyond all all
technology and it's like yeah well it's
a weather balloon and someone would go
Ah that's how you know how up the
world has gotten is that the UFO and the
government saying yeah okay why isn't
that ever all everyone they gotta get
they gotta give people a chance to write
the third Testament
[Music]
oh
and then adjust the story and say no but
God did give us the third Testament you
guys just weren't ready for it and here
it is yes from a weather balloon over
Florida yes dropping down and still God
loves us the best yeah and we still pray
to White Jesus